vive la foule mois président otis amène
d'ailleurs je voudrais vous dire
présentement que cette conférence des
plus doigt s'est passé dans la bonne
humeur
oui et je tiens à vous s'est signalé par
la même occasion que si les journalistes
ont deux présentement des questions à me
poser je suis toute ouïe répondre lui
même question pour la fréquence des
trains du match même si le président
maréchal mon frère je voudrais savoir
pourquoi
très bonne question je réponds nous et
où tu as le bon truc question pour le
journal minute
voilà ce que je voulais vous demander ce
que par rapport à ce qu'ils croyaient
pas que en ce qui concerne les études
comme moi je ne comprends pas non moi
j'ai des mois pour le journal minutes
voilà ce qui se passe c'est que j'ai
l'impression que malheureusement il ya
des petits problèmes en ce qui concerne
le wet water guette je pense oui pour
ici dimanche le couple dada se sépare la
princesse anne
ce couple est belle mais on dit tout de
même qu'il y à anguilles sous roche
entre la princesse
allez vous la placez salle est une
excellente cavalière
ce n'est pas une raison pour affirmer
que anne est adam
oui pour pour marie chantal et on dit au
président que les noirs vous voyez ce
que je veux dire oui madame tout temps
le oui pour l'équipe quel sens peur est
ce que vous croyez pas que il serait bon
que disons que ce serait assez valable
pour vous si vous aviez sur les stades
de haute compétition parce qu il faut
dire que chez vous vous êtes assez nul à
ce qui ne vous inquiétez pas nous avons
toujours battu les blancs en neige
eh bien il n'y a plus de question donc
je terminerais c'était conférence de
presse en tirant cette maxime de mon
petit livret blanc qui dit aoun a connu
un moment qu'une autre grande arnaque
rona autrement dit plus gênant le moins
vite moins j'avance plus fort de toute
manière ghana reste à celle de cheval